[Musique]
c'est une de nos plus grandes
comédiennes julie barennes bonsoir le
problème c'est que je vieillis plein
drôle que je peux plus jouer tu vas
quand même pas loin du style unique
toujours si votre plus grande fan
c'est totalement troué et l'horreur
c'est très très bien
c'est aurait complètement défiguré
augurer un poisson mort ne sont jamais
contente
le tournage démarre lundi c'est
l'occasion inespérée de faire repartir
ta carrière tu peux pas faire un film
avec cette technique a sûrement une
solution cherche une doublure
alors si on vous relooker un peu je suis
sûr vous pourriez me remplacer incognito
bien sûr alors c'est quoi votre taille
38 je trouve que vous faites un peu plus
si là vous allez être actrice une
actrice ça mange pas à vous de jouer
distante
bonjour gêné bonjour bonjour 10 est
pareil à les odieuses inscrits sur tout
ce qui bougeait bonjour non ceci n'est
pas du tout comme j'imagine et elle est
fraîche et spontanée à lavera sens du
rythme elle a complètement le côté
solaire du personnage maman
incroyable cette ressemblance entre
julie et vous c'est sa soeur jumelle tu
es devenu complètement fou attention
juifs
à force de traiter les gens comme de la
merde tu vas finir par se retrouver tout
seul
vous avez peur de vous attacher
évidemment mon avis ce qui est un fossé
infranchissable entre nous
ça fait des années qu'on parle de
testeurs que tu rêves du moment
merveilleux où vous allez enfin vous
retrouver
suis pas vraiment réussi à maintenir la
distance dont vous m'aviez parlé à
demain ne dites pas que vous fait la
bise à tout le monde